usually when we talk about how the 2020
Democratic primary is looking we talk
about national polls and in national
polls Joe Biden has and is leading
followed by Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders who have sort of been trading
off second and third-place but that's
national polling and in practice the
primaries don't happen all at once they
don't happen all on one day the first
caucus is February 3rd in Iowa the first
primary is February 11th in New
Hampshire
and so New Hampshire is a very important
early state in setting the tone of the
primaries but at the same time we don't
want to give New Hampshire more
importance than it actually has because
remember that in 2016 Bernie Sanders
handily won the New Hampshire primary
over Hillary Clinton but ultimately was
not the Democratic nominee so let's look
at New Hampshire in New Hampshire there
is a new poll that is getting a lot of
attention in which Bernie Sanders has
passed Joe Biden the poll is from gravis
Biden has been leading every New
Hampshire poll dating all the way back
to who even knows I mean a long time
dating too before he even announced that
he was actually running and now we have
one new poll in which Bernie Sanders has
passed Biden sort of Bernie Sanders at
21 Joe Biden at 15 but the poll has a
6.2 percent margin of error and only 250
primary voters were actually asked their
view on who they will vote for in the
primary so in reality again I'm just the
messenger here I'm just looking at
what's on the screen in reality even
though Bernie Sanders is leading Joe
Biden by 6 the poll has a 6.2 percent
margin of error and it is a statistical
tie so some people are maybe making more
of a big deal out of this poll than they
should this is one poll within the
margin of error but the trend has been a
clearly anti Biden trend in New
Hampshire now some other important
caveats I'm not being positive or
negative I'm not a Biden guy I'm a
Bernie Warren guy I'm just being a
realist New Hampshire is Vermont's
neighbor Bernie is from New Hampshire
winning New Hampshire in 20
would not really be a sign of anything
for Bernie Sanders in the sense that he
crushed Hillary there in the 2016
primary 62 38 and ultimately lost the
nomination I would actually go further
if Bernie Sanders doesn't win New
Hampshire on February 11th of 2020 it's
probably a really bad sign for him in
the 2020 Democratic primary because it
is a state that he's so easily won in
2016 so this is valuable in showing us a
trend line it's valuable in that every
primary is worth some Delegates and the
more you win the more delegates you have
towards the nomination we just don't
want to give more value to this one poll
in one state that Bernie won in 2016
anyway then it deserves now there's
another interesting data point from this
poll when it comes to electability and
the matchups versus Trump New Hampshire
voters say they voted for Trump 51 to 41
and for Biden over Trump by an even
bigger margin 53 to 40 this is
interesting because if you look back at
2016 in the general Hillary Clinton won
New Hampshire but she won by 0.37%
if the Democratic candidate wins New
Hampshire in 2020 doesn't matter who it
is at this point by 3 by 4 by 6 by 10 by
13 the way this poll is suggesting this
would be a massive signal in terms of
the broader election but that being said
it's early both of these margins fifty
one forty one and fifty three forty they
include like 7 to 8% undecided or third
party voters that is not going to be the
reality by election day but even if all
of the currently undecided and third
party voters shift to trump by Election
Day
these would still be bigger wins in 2020
in New Hampshire than Hillary Clinton
had and it could be a pretty big signal
for 2020 it's all speculative it's all
hypothetical it's very early
everyone must vote no matter what you
think is likely to happen in your state
assume everybody should operate under
the belief which may end up not being
wrong that every state could be 50/50
and your vote could make the difference
I mean literally speaking that's not
going to be the case but that
the attitude every single one of us
needs to have I'll be voting in the
primary I'll be voting in the general
even though I vote here in Massachusetts
once again as far as New Hampshire is
concerned this is one poll relatively
small sample size statistical tie
nothing can be assumed every vote has to
be cast and counted my question for you
today relates to the quality of the
campaign that Joe Biden is running does
anybody in my audience think that Joe
Biden is running a good campaign so I'm
not asking you about electability I'm
not asking you about whether you agree
with him on the issues what I'm asking
is as far as campaign strategy and
visibility and logistics and debate
strategy are concerned does anyone in my
audience believe that Joe Biden is
running a strong campaign I don't see it
I want to hear from you make sure you're
following us on instagram at david
pakman show and while you're there
follow me on instagram at David Pakman
for the latest urban farming tomato
update big big updates big news there
check it out we'll take a quick break
and talk to you in a moment
today's sponsor is Skillshare and i'm
excited to tell you that everybody in
our audience is getting two entire
months of free access to Skillshare when
you click the link underneath this video
skill shares the site that offers over
25,000 online courses on almost any
topic you can imagine cooking meditation
photography video editing Photoshop
managing a small business almost an
endless list and whether you're trying
to get ahead in your career maybe you
want to learn new skills that will make
you better at your job you might just be
exploring a new hobby and you're trying
to find new ways to be creative in your
personal time skill shares the perfect
place to fully immerse yourself in
whatever you're trying to learn I really
enjoyed the class on more advanced video
editing techniques because it's
something I've been wanting to improve
at but have been very busy hosting the
david packard show for the last few
years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep
your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're passionate about or discover
something brand-new that you didn't even
know that you would love and join skill
shares other 7 million users by clicking
the link underneath this video
[Music]